[Music]
you know
to celebrate
the 200th episode
i thought we could let out
one of our clones oh
okay you sure yeah i think are you sure
we haven't gotten it right though it's
like they're still all [ __ ] up it
might be weird yeah they'll be okay and
just to interview them or what yeah we
just talked to them okay they have the
same brain i'm pretty sure as the yeah
the originals
oh i see you know as far as you know i
don't know what rating system they use
for pokemon cards but
we're we're damn near perfect
you know
yeah with the brain but we still don't
have the nerve function yeah all that's
actually correct yeah so yeah
he might be in pain when he gets happier
we'll see as long as he can talk it's
all right yeah i'm fine with that let's
do it let's calm up
hey candace can we get uh
josh richards clone up here please
i'm freezing now
thank you
[Music]
oh [ __ ] there he is
right over there man
oh sorry
good to see you man
you all right no
no
damn
everything hurts oh yeah sorry
excruciating pain actually forever so we
did not get his skin right yeah we
really [ __ ] it up we just want to
apologize dude it was you think eh
yeah it was an experiment that kind of
went we got pretty close though we got
very close we just kind of [ __ ] up the
face the face big time yeah and the
nerve endings no yeah it sucks to jerk
off does it sucks you can jerk off down
there
yeah clones get up to it
do they
what else are we gonna do yeah i guess
that's true yeah they are just in those
cages yeah that's true
yeah so like you jerk off and like bryce
is like right beside you i mean
sometimes sometimes they like we switch
around
like team jerk oh okay cool huh we're
aggressive man yeah no no
so
damn thanks for thanks for coming up
dude yeah thanks for letting me out yeah
nice no problem no it's dope to be like
in a different room for once so
it's sick we should definitely let you
out more i feel like that's kind of mean
yeah we don't really spend enough time
with our clones i know
so but it's the 200th episode so yeah we
thought why the [ __ ] not yeah just spend
some time
i'm here i'm here entertaining and you
have the same brain as earth josh
the yeah uh just not the same life at
all okay yeah got it is that weird
experience
obviously more pain as we were saying
right yeah right
is it just always pain it doesn't end
okay 24 hours a day 24. 25. wow we
really [ __ ] that up we did [ __ ] yeah
dang see the stand accounts are really
going to misinterpret that as well yeah
oh he's always in pain yeah
i'm in pain as i once said good quote
well uh thanks for coming on bro so what
are you up to these days
i mean i s
oh my dungeon yeah the real josh sorry
right yeah
i mean him uh
[ __ ] i guess the biggest thing right now
is probably
the production company he has with mark
wahlberg that he has heard you have well
he because i'm the clone okay okay got
it right you know what i'm saying right
right he doesn't have [ __ ]
i got pain like we said yeah i'm just
hurting again every day all day yeah we
got some advil in the back we can give
you no that'd be sick
bill we'll fix that but yeah i think
it's a
i feel like i need some [ __ ] ointment
yeah yeah
yeah something yeah just don't look in
the mirror
you guys have deprived us as mirrors so
we can actually only imagine what we
look like it's not pretty
unfortunately no thanks yeah kind of you
actually could have lied made me feel
better
no it's rough
it looks bad it's tough for me to look
at right now
it's like exactly what ugly people
wished the real you looked like
[Laughter]
does that make sense
yeah i see where i see what you're
saying for sure yeah it's like anyone
who envies the real josh's perfect skin
this is what they wished you looked like
maybe maybe
sorry sorry sorry sorry
maybe it's a little real the clone the
clone as me yeah um
maybe they get more followers then just
the relatable factor you know they just
play that card that's true yeah yeah so
maybe you guys should really let me out
of here
no because then you'd be more popular
than us and that'd be the [ __ ] worst
i actually can't wait to see the fan
cams after this yeah
these are the most perfect boils i've
ever seen
zombie wait zombie josh though the crazy
part is they're not even gonna know that
it's not the real him
yeah right that's true yeah so
uh oh my god the way his jaw is hanging
out of his skin
cut me with that i love his jaw
his jawbone's so hot
he's so structured
see i told you he was perfect
look at the way his bones run oh my god
the puss running out of the wounds
it's perfect pause
[Laughter]
i would eat up his puss honestly
[Laughter]
laughing hurts too
[Laughter]
jesus christ so real josh has a
production company with mark wahlberg
yeah and it's going well lucky son of a
[ __ ]
but no yeah he
he seems to be doing good with it uh
doing a lot of projects right now
focusing a lot on unscripted because
it's teamed up with mark's unscripted uh
production company so
are you the co-owner of this
the josh's yeah yeah sorry i'm gonna
keep referring to you
yeah let's just do that now look yeah so
i don't have to keep correcting besides
the [ __ ] up face you guys look almost
identical
so yeah that's my bad but no it's good
you gotta remind him that his face is
[ __ ] like
no it's sick it's sick actually
it's like imagine i reminded you were
short every time i talked to you dude
yeah yeah the real cody is 605. right
right right that's [ __ ]
you up as well
just a couple [ __ ] up guys
yeah but no one knows is we're just
clones of the realest to realize
yeah where'd those guys at tall rip dude
gigantic penises yeah yeah sick hair
away
they got that one right yeah i guess i
got that part right
the real me is
[ __ ]
how's the podcast going
podcast podcast is killing it from what
i see in my dungeon when i'm watching
the episodes
um
no they're great we gave you a [ __ ]
tv no we had to smuggle that [ __ ] yeah
check it out get out that [ __ ] there's
a little like 1995 long ass tiny tv yeah
yeah yeah yeah we're just like on
youtube somehow yeah um no but the
podcast has been doing amazing like
dave's obviously a character right so
it's it's giving me a whole new
demographic as well and giving dave a
new demo that was the whole plan going
into it it's like he's touching into
this tick tock area and then i had no
mail fans like i mean
i would walk down the street and it's
like me the only time a guy came up to
me is if he was going to say something
like slur at me and call me gay or
something you know what i'm saying wow
like that was it it was it was brutal
like there's a clip on tmz i think i'm
walking and like
the odd one time in my life ever i
[ __ ] i'm hanging out with jacob
sartorius right and and this and then
we're
walking down melrose and this is like
when i was like 17 i think and these
like five guys walk by us and they start
yerping us because they see that like
there's tmz filming right so they're
like oh this would be funny like uh
so they just started your opinion nice
boils
nice boils who let you out of the
nice jawbone it is actually a segment
so we ended up we ended up like i ended
up turning around in the middle of the
paparazzi video and just started like
walking them down because i was like i'm
not going to get bitched out on like tv
that would suck yeah so i started like
walking and i think like tmz just didn't
even follow me because they were like we
don't give a [ __ ] about you we're
filming jacob right like i was nobody at
this time i was like you're just a dude
yeah [ __ ] hold on
[Laughter]
yeah just like walked up started europe
but like that was that was like the mail
demo like that's what i would have
interactions with and then now after the
bar stool i think like one i was able to
show more depth of who like josh
richards was beside just like
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
that type of [ __ ] and then and then what
you were doing what was that
wow that was a wow that was a clone move
though like we don't know all the
updated true true true yeah yeah
um yeah
that's what we're doing down there
just clones stupid clone moves
[Laughter]
yeah
so that's that's what we'd be doing in
the basement
but no it just gave me that demo like
now i'll go to sports games or go
wherever and it's like oh [ __ ] like
there's guys everywhere like i used to
be able to go to like a hockey game or
something would not have to worry about
anything yeah don't have to worry about
a picture nothing and now it's like
which is super cool yeah it's crazy to
see the hell yeah dude all only dudes
now love my dudes dudes that's what i'm
talking about all the guys [ __ ] girls
get that get that dude in my in my
fandom hell yeah
now all the dudes that were chirping at
you
are chirping at you and then
asking for a photo after
yo what's up man you look gay
i would love a picture yeah you're
awesome man dude for sure man i love
when dudes enter my fandom
i feel like it's different because you
guys
always slip into my fandom my god let's
take a pic yo fellas
josh richards here you guys had guys
from the start so it's so easy like oh
yeah so we get we get guys
all day every day man
yeah what up it's your boy josh richards
and i just want to give a shout out to
all the fellows out there who want to
slip into my fandom want to slip in
these boils yeah all right who wants to
slip up on this puss
dude is it is pus not the worst word it
is the english language yeah poss
i said puss i think on action i think
he's a [ __ ] slip into my puss
oh we really [ __ ] up the clones yeah
we really did not get them
completely accurate damn yeah but i'm
batting like a load
100 so
the clones are [ __ ]
um
oh [ __ ] so i
bryce waking up
where's my [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's just smooth give me a dumbbell
it's just smooth it looks like a ken
doll down there there's just nothing
it's just soft skin
that's brutal he'll cry because it would
hurt
laughing and that hurts too
everything hurts
wow even screaming hurts the salt from
the tears like sting my boils oh yeah
the thing that trips me how old are you
19.
the [ __ ]
like we talk about this [ __ ] all the
time when any of us were 19 we did not
talk
like you yeah why were you talking yeah
man i was doing calls and then i got a
[ __ ] this and that no 19 year old had
that yeah yeah i was like i have um
biology
i was in a writing class
when i was a sophomore in college
called the biology of apes where i was
just
writing about how bonobos have sex
that's what i was doing when i was 19.
that's kind of cool yeah yeah i don't
know if i'd pass that up
don jin writing about apes having sex
well the real josh would be like
oh that's cool i'm working on a movie
about apes having yeah if i was
[Laughter]
damn what were you doing when you're 19.
i'm trying to think i was i think i was
working
three jobs only one of them paid
yeah i was working at best buy yeah i
was interning at a music studio getting
humiliated every day and then i worked
for like an artist management company i
was interning there sort of humiliating
myself they gave me free merch and stuff
so you always were trying to do music
stuff like um yeah why you guys did like
the tiny meat gang music like you were
just always into that i mean it was that
was because we wanted to make sick ass
music yeah right you just wanted to [ __ ]
all the time just get hella roadies yes
we wanted roadies that's sick yeah yeah
yeah two engineers sat out and were like
we should make music and get roadies
that would work well for us yeah where
are the girls
it was actually like some corny disney
movie [ __ ] because
cody wanted to you know
make some kind of like goofy song and
uh he was like come on let's just do it
and i was like nah man
that part of my life is over
yeah
that's beneath me now that chapter is
closed i was basically like so he had to
like he had to like pull you out of that
that yeah i was like i made a beat wow
just come over and just for like an hour
and that's just freestyle do some stupid
[ __ ] on it
dude i can't man it was basically fast
and furious with music yeah yeah right
right right cody was the cop you guys
ever see like you've seen those
all-american memes at all about uh on
tick talk about the
that main character dude that's always
just like
i don't need help i like he's always
just like super in denial the entire
[ __ ] you guys don't know of what fast
all american
oh it's all american damn really what is
that it's like a football show yeah yeah
yeah right now it's like huge oh really
i've definitely seen that i've never
heard of that i know that's though
well yeah i know that [ __ ] [ __ ] up
again i'm 16 man i know that show i mean
like all right
but yeah that was basically me like all
right yeah yeah no i got it and then he
came and he
you know put down his his verse like
apprehensively and then he did that and
i looked at him and said where'd you
learn how to rap like that
i was like
this is really some like easy east right
out of compton hopping in the studio
that's awesome
i did two years in law park i'll die
before i go
back and cody was like you gotta do
another verse man
and then yeah rest rest is here it's
famous that's how one yeah it's for
family
you have to quickly shout out vinnie
bennett the dude who played young vin
diesel in the new fast nine i hung out
with him recently
and i was like dude do a fast nine line
he's from new zealand right he's like
the most laid-back dude ever when he
went into like young dom mode i was
dying because he's like oh okay hold on
hold on
but he's like hold on hold on or no no
can't do new zealand hold on a no no
that's no
horrible
yeah
it sounded like you had like an ice cube
in your mouth yes hold on
right that's not new zealand right yeah
well done how's that
no
okay yeah i'll shut the [ __ ] up yeah
let me sound like you were drowning a
little bit
he looks to cameron he just goes like
his voice goes like two octaves deeper
and he's like it's all about family like
american as [ __ ] i'm like how do you do
that
he's like i don't know man i'm just
watching american tv and i just act like
you guys i'm like that's crazy anyway
yeah
congratulations oh you've completed your
200th episode oh
sick hey man thanks for being a part no
no problem yeah oh yeah all right get
the [ __ ] back down downstairs
keep moving
just in case yeah yeah
all right